when the pandemic started businesses
forced to close the future was really
unpredictable business owners say they
never thought
bringing back workers would be the
problem they would run into
joe mohler shows us how some are still
dealing with the impact
[Music]
whether it be deep south creole deep
south cajun
i love louisiana and i love louisiana
cuisine
lola pokorny brought new orleans style
cuisine to las vegas
all i'm from louisiana and i
did catering here like i said for 15 17
years prior to opening
lola's downtown she opened lola's
louisiana kitchen with a location in
summerlin and downtown las vegas
my firstborn restaurant is now
permanently closed
and it's not due to covid but it's due
to the aftermath
of covet so i guess you could say it's a
covet victim
we are not able to staff it
the corny says they couldn't find people
to work at the downtown location
she says it is still challenging with
stabbing at summerlin too
and just when she thinks they will get
some new hires we asked them
are you taking this interview only
to extend your unemployment and they
will tell us
yes so we know they're not going to show
up
the extra 300 weekly benefits are
continuing for many states including
nevada
some say the extra money is stopping
people from heading back to work
at this point i think 24 governors
have suspended payment of
federal benefits chris o'leary is a
senior economist at the upjohn institute
for employment research
he says the extra benefits could play a
role but may not be the only reason why
hiring is difficult
whether or not it's the unemployment
benefits or the additional unemployment
benefits we'll have to wait and see
until that until that ends
the extra benefits are set to end in
september
i'd have tons of people apply for the
job
90 of them didn't qualify the 10 percent
who did i would set up interviews
maybe 10 interviews out of the 10
interviews one or two people would
actually show
up alexandria lightning recently opened
up medical practice in henderson during
the pandemic
hiring has not been easy for her either
she is getting creative with jobs she
does have
traditionally we do have everybody on
site but one of my main
leads my office manager i actually do
allow her to work home remotely
so that she can still have that work
life balance that she desires
businesses across the valley are finding
themselves in the same boat with hiring
signs out
time will tell if the lingering problem
will disappear this is happening
countrywide and it's got to come to an
end
no one can tell us when that's going to
happen joe moeller 8 news now
thank you joe all this week we are
taking a deeper look at the problems
the pandemic created from hiring to
older workers
retraining adapting to remote work and
hot jobs post pandemic
we're bringing you those stories right
here on 8 news now